devin clegg's son is finally released
from the hospital this after the 90 day
fiance star shared that three-year-old
taehyung was battling cancer
[Music]
but it's a bittersweet homecoming for
devin's little boy whom she shares with
ex jihoon lee on thursday the reality
star posted an update on instagram
here's devin and her son getting cozy at
home and she's holding him a little
tighter these days she wrote in part
taeyong was so happy to be back home and
have morning cuddles
and guys as you can imagine this is just
the beginning for taeyong's leukemia
battle tay has already undergone
multiple procedures ahead of his release
from the hospital devon gave her
followers a glimpse of the road ahead
adding quote we are now starting his
outpatient treatment we will go back to
the hospital twice a week for chemo
monday we have another procedure
when devin first revealed taeyong's
cancer diagnosis she said it flipped our
lives upside down she's now leaning on
her online community to help setting up
a gofundme and selling t-shirts to raise
proceeds to cover tay's medical expenses
the reality star wrote childhood cancer
is one of the worst things to happen to
anyone or any family
fans of 90 day fiance will recall devin
and gian met online and found out they
were expecting in an unexpected way
the day jihoon was actually leaving for
korea i did not feel good
and he made the joke you know maybe
you're pregnant
i take the test
instantly two lines which is positive
[Music]
i instantly assumed i would never see
jihyun again
but when jihoon actually got back to
korea the first text message they got
from him was saying
well we have to get married now
taehyung's parents have since called it
quits but the salt lake city native had
support from boyfriend topher park the
pair had their own share of
heartbreaking news after suffering a
miscarriage in 2021. she and topher are
now pregnant again this will be their
first child together
someone share with me
and topher is already on daddy duty with
devin's other kids daughter driscilla
and little tay
wow
it's so good
this is the pumpkin cheesecake
[Music]
you